lettre de motivation CV ou encore
navigation sur le Web ces tâches n'ont
plus de secret pour ces femmes venus
symboliquement récupérer leur passeport
numérique au Centre d'Information sur
les Droits des femmes et des familles
des Yvelines elles ont toutes participé
à 12 ateliers numériques entre mars et
juillet dernier il y a deux niveaux le
premier niveau c'est vraiment pour des
personnes qui n'ont c'est l'initiation
alors qu'il utilise peu ou pas du tout
le deuxième niveau c'est du
perfectionnement une collaboration entre
le CIDFF des Yvelines et la Fondation
Orange qui a été mise en place en 2017
la Fondation Orange a apporté un
financement de 3000 euros et fourni des
formateurs numériques une aide
primordiale pour ces femmes d'autant que
l'éloignement du numérique conduit très
vite à l'exclusion sociale des ateliers
comme ça qui vous met à l'aise avec des
plantes qui sont bien sur tout ça et ben
je pense que ça va aider beaucoup de
tout le monde on est aussi conscient en
tant que Orange
structure responsable que être éloigné
du numérique c'est ce qui arrive pour
certaines personnes et on veut lutter
contre cette fracture numérique et on
sait que les femmes grâce au numérique
peuvent devenir plus autonomes on peut
le mettre sur notre CV donc comme j'ai
dit c'est vraiment un appui donc voilà
ça passe très très bien dans le CV c'est
pour prouver qu'on est passé par la case
atelier informatique un tremplin
également pour l'insertion
professionnelle quel que soit l'emploi
l'utilisation des basiques ou hors
d'excels c'est le minimum et ça leur
permet d'être beaucoup plus à l'aise
devant un employeur si elle doit
ne serait-ce que faire une prise de
commande pour certains dans le métier du
commerce ou de la gestion de commandes
au total 40 femmes sont formées au
numérique chaque année au CIDFF 78